Demon's machines employees knew they
were doing something fraudulent very few
of them knew about this that the demos
were her insights are crowded in secrecy
it was a very small circle of people who
knew about the bogus demos and it was a
very small circle of people who knew
that the Siemens machines had been
hacked and in fact in in the later
versions of the Thera nosed laboratory
you couldn't get in to the laboratory
where the Siemens machines were that had
been hacked unless you were an
authorized member of the lab whose
fingerprint was you know basically they
had fingerprint scanners on his own he
created this level of secrecy and
security that mimicked Steve Jobs is
right but instead of doing necklace he
didn't want to see all the fail designs
that he and Johnny I've worked on for
the iPhone she was literally doctoring
the blood tests and it's been confirmed
by multiple people now yeah I mean she
and her boyfriend Sonny bomani who was
the number two of the company this
president he was like a chef engali kind
of figure as well I pushed back against
the notion that he was controlling her
and that he was like the puppet master
that that's not the case it was a
partnership of equals they were running
in this fraud together and ultimately
she always had the last say if there was
something she didn't agree with
she had the veto power so he was just a
sycophant partner in crime right I mean
in to some extent he was using her and
she was using them but he was not
manipulating her I addressed that in the
epilogue and I push back very strongly
against she's not the victim here she
created this whole fraud she controlled
99 percent of the voting rights of the
company the board couldn't even reach a
quorum without her right and you tell
early on in the book the board tried to
fire her the early board and she talked
her way she talks her way out of it